[Music]
let us to begin with not question the
assumption that there is an actual moral
consciousness because the assumption is
made directly an on in connection with
something preceding and let us turn to
the harmony of morality in nature the
first postulate it is supposed to be an
implicit harmony not explicitly for
actual consciousness not present on the
contrary what is present is rather only
the contradiction of the two in the
present morality is assumed is already
in existence an actuality is soul placed
that it is not in harmony with it the
actual moral consciousness however is
one that acts it is precisely there in
that the actuality of its morality
consists but in the very doing or acting
the place given to actuality is
displaced for the action is nothing
other than the actualization of the
inner moral purpose nothing other than
the production of an actuality
determined by the purpose or of the
harmony of the moral purpose and
actuality itself at the same time the
performance of the action is a fact of
which consciousness is aware it is the
presence of this unity of actuality and
purpose and because in the accomplished
deed consciousness knows itself to be
actualized as this particular
consciousness or B holds existence
returned into itself and enjoyment
consists in this there is also contained
in the actuality of the moral purpose
that form of actuality which is called
enjoyment and happiness action therefore
in fact directly fulfills what was
asserted could not take place what was
supposed to be merely a postulate merely
a beyond consciousness thus proclaims
through its deed that it is not in
earnest in making its postulate because
the meaning of the action is really this
to make into a present reality what was
not supposed to exist in the present and
since the Harmony is postulated for the
sake of the action that is to say what
is to become actual through action must
be so in itself otherwise actuality
would not be possible the connection of
action and posture that is so
constituted
that for the sake of the action that is
for the sake of the actual harmony of
purpose in actuality this harmony is
postulated as not actual as a beyond
in paragraph 618 Hagel is now exploring
in a bit more specificity what is
actually going on in the development and
the overcoming of its its own
contradictions within moral
self-consciousness the further
elaboration of the moral view of the
world so that it can take into account
these different roadblocks and
cul-de-sacs and places where we
seemingly have to go off-road and
eventually bringing them into a fuller
unity and we saw that there was a
synthetic unity as he said achieved at
the end of the previous section but now
he's retracing this ground going a bit
deeper and examining where the
contradictions that have to be unpacked
examined and worked through actually lie
he begins this paragraph by saying let
us to begin with not question the
assumption that there is an actual moral
consciousness and you remember that this
was in fact one of the propositions that
in the previous paragraph we were
oscillating between right there is a
moral consciousness there is no moral
actuality how do we bring those two
together in this synthetic unity that he
had already sketched out so he says
let's just begin with that we're going
to accept it we're going to postulate
there we're not going to question the
assumption there is an actual moral
consciousness why because the assumption
is made directly and not in connection
with something preceding and now why is
he saying that well one way of
understanding this is to look at how it
is that we as human beings do in fact
comport ourselves within a universe
within a world the cosmos that we do in
fact recognize to have moral dimensions
and those moral dimensions in particular
stem in large part from us from our
involve
element in it from our engagement in it
and those are the things that we find
ear a summated in our culture that is
rooted within the very cultural matrix
within which we live remember that
culture was an earlier section in this
before we got to morality and he goes on
and he says what we're going to look at
is this harmony of morality and nature
the first postulate the first thing that
as moral beings attempting to in fact be
moral in relation to actuality in the
world that we have to think accept
imagine that we have to take for a
starting point now Hegel goes on and he
says we can look at this in an implicit
way we can also look at this in an
explicit way what were confronted with
explicitly he tells us is the
contradiction of these two the
contradiction between morality or duty
and its demands it might also be thought
of as the the contradiction between
morality as the pure will although
that's more about the second postulate
and nature or actuality Berkeley okay
what we've been talking about now for
paragraph after paragraph after
paragraph and the realm of nature we
should remind ourselves is a realm that
is supposed to encompass the entire
phenomenal world it also not just
includes physical laws about how things
interact physically chemically
biochemically but it also includes
psychological sociological we could call
human scientific understandings of
things and some of these are just sort
of broad generalizations and some of
these are ways that we can describe our
fundamental motivations as beings that
exist within a universe that is shared
with other beings so we have this this
fundamental contradiction Avitus brook
between these two sometimes call
antithesis in other parts and how do we
bring them together Hegel says that
there is an implicit harmony between
them what is this he says it's supposed
to be an implicit harmony not explicitly
for actual consciousness not present so
what would be implicit here the implicit
is what is yet to be worked out to be
worked through but something that is
possible something that is imaginable at
the very least if not strictly speaking
imaginable in the sense that you can
create a force telling a representation
in your mind that's entirely coherent at
least imaginable or represent a table in
the sense of we can formulate sentences
about it we can say this harmony of
morality and nature and we're not
talking pure nonsense or gobbledygook or
meaningless syllables placed in relation
to each other it may be it turns out
something like talking about squaring
the circle or wooden iron something that
turns out to be radically incoherent but
when we're postulating it we're saying
we're going to assume for the moment
that it's not incoherent and see if we
can't actually work this out a
reconciliation of sorts within the
logical sphere of what is a morality
applying to us and nature that we exist
in as natural beings so he goes on and
he says in the present morality is being
assumed as already in existence let's
pause on that for a moment what are we
talking about is saying that morality is
assumed as already in existence do we
mean that we as beings that come on the
scene in two cultures that already exist
prior to our own existence encounter
moral codes that then are imposed upon
us and we orient ourselves within them
oftentimes fighting against them you
know as natural beings and events
getting shaped into the sort of beings
the moral beings that morality demands
of us well that's one way to interpret
it or do we mean something a little bit
more basic that within say the family or
within some very elementary institutions
or associations that we inevitably run
across certain rules that perhaps we
learn experientially like if you want to
be treated well by others you should
treat them well Henkel doesn't actually
seem to think that that is what morality
would consist in no neither did cottony
did others to begin with that that lacks
even generality there's so many
exceptions to that sort of thing but it
also would that would be more the
ethical right Hegel doesn't talk about
that he talks about moral consciousness
so it's not simply that we encounter
maybe the fabric of the world teaching
us certain lessons or that there's
something in some way transcendent to
the world that is imposed on us from
without nor is it merely a code that's
out there in culture providing us with
our basic building blocks although
they're ones that we kick against a lot
no there there is an actual moral
consciousness and we are that moral
consciousness according to Hegel so he
says morality is assumed as already
exist as in existence in us right an
actuality is so placed that it's not in
harmony with it one you know basic
example of realizing that nature is not
in harmony with morality is when we
behave as moral beings and we see other
human beings behaving in immoral
fashions and not immediately being
punished for it or we don't get rewarded
we actually get treated badly it doesn't
pay off whether in the sense of the what
Bentham called the social sanction or
the political sanction which is other
people affecting us
or even in terms of doing the right
thing and then not getting pleasure out
of it getting pain instead I do the
right thing by giving somebody my last
loaf of bread who is dying I get to be
hungry as a result and that's just a
very prosaic example of the disharmony
between nature and morality
so he says actuality is so placed it's
not in harmony with morality but here's
the key transition point of this
paragraph the actual moral consciousness
moral consciousness in existence is one
that acts here the word is handled right
one that engages in comportment in
behavior in determinate ways of
affecting things you might say there's a
lot of other things rolled up in this
volition choice perhaps even
deliberation it does things it attempts
to make the moral actual so he says it
is precisely there in that the
actualities of morality consists that's
a very important point isn't it
this is one that he's going to return to
by the way in the later section
following this the beautiful soul if you
claim to be moral but you don't do moral
things you're not moral you're a moral
or anti moral and you're not making
morality exist in the world it only
exists in the world if you do the right
things when you when it's called for by
you when you impose morality upon
reality or actuality and you're part of
that actuality or that reality doing
that very action aren't you so you're a
part of the natural world that exceeds
the natural world imposing something
that goes beyond the natural world upon
the natural world so he says in this
very doing or acting the place given to
actuality is an interesting way of
talking about is displaced in this
harkens back to the preview
paragraph where we saw this oscillation
and this sort of it is sort of imperfect
or only partial of hey bong taking place
he says why the action is nothing other
than the actualization of the inner
moral purposely being made actual the
you know you might say realization would
be another way of translating this
relation to veer Clete kite nothing
other he says than the production and
this is a key term of an actuality
determined by the purpose and the the
German for that a dirt vac Bosch temptin
vehicle II cut an actuality that is
determined through the purpose that has
given determination by having a purpose
and end a goal it's not just that you
act and then find the goal afterwards
you have a goal and what is this goal
well much of our action is goal oriented
towards something that's kind of at a
low level but Hegel says that here what
is the purpose the harmony of the moral
purpose and actuality itself so there's
a kind of self referential thing to this
that goes on if we actually are trying
to be moral we not only want to do the
right thing is in the sense of following
the code or responding appropriately
appropriately at the right moment we
want to be in harmony as beings that act
with morality itself the morality that
is dependent upon us for introducing
into actuality he goes on he says the
performance of the action is a fact of
which consciousness is aware in acting I
am aware that the action is my action
that I am the one doing it and we might
object here well as Hegel saying this is
the case for all action no no there's
plenty of actions where we are not
conscious that it's we who are acting we
attribute it to somebody else
the cop-outs are like this defense
mechanisms
it's the other person who's really
making me do this sort of thing no we're
choosing to do it and we're responsible
for it but we push it off on the other
to do that but when it comes to moral
action we can't really engage in those
sorts of evasions we are conscious of
the fact that we are doing those actions
so he says it is a fact of which
consciousness is aware it is the
presence of this unity of actuality and
purpose vehicle ik ITINs beck and
because in the accomplished deed the
accomplished action the product of that
he says consciousness knows itself to be
actualized as this particular
consciousness let's pause on that for a
moment I choose in a difficult situation
to do the right thing I don't lie about
the numbers that I'm being asked about
even though I'm afraid that if I don't
do that I'm going to incur some sort of
penalty people make fun of me people
will take my job away from me I will go
to prison I choose to tell the truth
even though it's going to you know be
difficult for me and it's also a truth
that may get other people into trouble
so I'll lose their their respect their
esteem want one of it that I have it
really isn't a little hell of a lot of
respect for liars and cheaters but but
it lets assume that that's something
that's motivating me I become aware of
the fact very painfully and lonely aware
of the fact that I am acting as an
individual I am making a choice to do
the right thing to bring about something
that goes against the dirty rotten
actuality that's out there most of the
time and introduce something bright
something wonderful something perhaps
even terrifying into existence morality
and its demands are not always lightness
you know sweetness and hope quite often
they're much more stark than that
so he says the presence of this unity of
actuality and purpose consciousness
knows itself to be actualized this
particular conscious
or be holds existence returned into
itself there's a sort of reflexivity
here as well I become aware of myself as
an acting existing being through moral
action and there he says enjoyment
consists in this that is something that
is well worth pausing on enjoyment what
is enjoyment sometimes we enjoy a
particular pleasure I I enjoy drinking
coffee you know I like the taste of it I
like the effects of the caffeine on
myself I like not being droopy and and
irritable in the morning when I want
some coffee
that's enjoyment in one sense is there a
deeper enjoyment that we can have yes
and this is running throughout the core
of the phenomenology we want to know who
we are and what we are and we want to do
so as beings that have a reflexive
relation to ourselves and that are
related to the other the whole you know
capital all other of the other
self-consciousness we desire recognition
honor Kenan from them and we also
through this dialectical process are
able to give recognition to ourselves we
are able to understand who we are
through our moral action or painfully
through our moral failures we can be
deluded about this deceived about this
we can act in ways that we think are
purely moral and as Kant pointed out
there may be a hidden spring of self
love at the bottom of all of that but
that doesn't mean that we don't enjoy
some sort of satisfaction in this some
sort of enjoyment so he says there is
also contained in the actuality of the
moral
that form of actuality which is called
enjoyment and happiness this sets up a
fundamental problem that concha and
morality and other you might say allied
forms of morality we're attempting to
understand and then come down very hard
on one side if we're getting something
out of it is it really moral you Diamond
ISM which Kant condemned and which Hegel
in a limited way is endorsing here says
we act and we should act for our own
happiness and not our own happiness in a
very selfish egoistic way but for the
full realization of what it is to be a
human being
think about Aristotle what does that
mean it means to live a life of virtuous
activity same thing for the Stoics same
thing for Augustine although Augustine
is going to displace it in the City of
God to a heavenly existence and
enjoyment of God in any case what we
really want is enjoyment of the highest
good for ourselves and that typically
involves enjoyment of the highest good
as being a good person for ourselves
which involves us inevitably with others
who we share this with Khans wants to
say all of that is besides the point
duty for the sake of Duty alone
recognized as the moral thing to do that
is what has value even Kant however
thinks that we enjoy some sort of
satisfaction self-respect the moral
feeling he discusses this in the beyond
the groundwork of the metaphysics of
morals in the actual metaphysics of
morals in the metaphysical elements of
virtue Hegel recognizes that conscience
at an extreme and anything that's like
hunt is at an extreme and that we need
to bring things back over here into this
ground where it is possible to have a
reconciliation of morality and happiness
not just of morality in nature so he
goes in and he says here we go
we have enjoyment happiness action
therefore does something what thought
could not do by itself
he says action directly fulfills what
was asserted could not take place what
was supposed to be merely a postulate
merely a beyond any action we go further
in acting in doing in trying something
out in making the ideal real we find
that there's more to the story
so he says consciousness thus proclaims
through its deed it is not in earnest in
making its postulate notice the deed is
more in earnest than the postulation is
because the meaning of the action really
is this he says to make into a present
reality what was not supposed to exist
in the present and we postulate he says
the Harmony for the sake of the action
we say what is to become actual through
action must be so in itself otherwise
the actuality would not be possible he
has a conclusion here the connection of
action and postulate postulate is so
constituted that for the sake of the
action for the sake of the actual
harmony of purpose and actuality this
harmony is postulated is not actual as
they beyond so we have a tangled
relationship here between the action and
the thought of it the imagination of it
the postulation of it action is what is
going to bring about at least in part
the harmony between morality and nature
it's going to do so individually
specifically in a determined determinant
the stemmed way hails saying you can
start with the postulate and then say
AHA the postulate
if not the roadmap for that at least the
inspiration for that and some people do
need that kind of inspiration but a lot
of times action surprises us we find
more as the product of action then we
originally postulated as a possibility
for that action and then we have to
revise things so the question here again
is is a sort of an oscillation which
side do we take that of the action or
that of the postulate which are we going
to place the emphasis on where is the
dialectic advancing
you